I actually met somebody that you used to  date she was in Dallas and scroll to me  that you guys had dated and you kind of  were off and Oliver he kind of blew her  off there was some trust stuff you don't  like that thing no I just  that's uh take it it's just an  interesting  I don't even know I don't even know what  to say there because you tell me earlier  today that you were ready now for  something serious like a Meritage yeah  but that you weren't before mm-hmm why  now unfortunately has a lot to do with  sports I was focused on one thing in my  life being the best football player I  could be when I wasn't I was tough and I  took it out on people so she was along  for the roller coaster of when I was at  my best and when I was at my worst I'll  be the first to admit that that was  awful and I wasn't the best person all  the time because